die burg hohenzollern ist ein beliebtes
foto motiv nicht nur für touristen
sondern auch für einheimische wie diese
fußballmannschaft aus dem nahegelegenen
steinhofen die poker und sollen diese
chance ein stück heimat wenn man sich
überlegt dass jede seite war eine halbe
million menschen hier als besucher
herkommt und wir haben sofort haustür
die burg aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
war schon kulisse für hollywoodfilme wie
in einem ritter märchen thront sie auf
den zoller werk ganz schön beeindruckend
was sich die hohenzollern familie da hat
bauen lassen
das besondere an dieser burg ist sie ist
ein nationales kulturdenkmal resultieren
daraus dass sie die dynastische
stammburg des geschlechts der
hohenzollern ist die sowohl die
deutschen könige als auch die deutschen
kaiser die natürlich dann preußen hießen
erstellten und somit besucher aus aller
welt hierher anlocken
in den schlussrunden erfahrt ihr mehr
über den hohenzollern klar
berühmtestes familienmitglied der
preußische könig friedrich der große
oder der letzte deutsche kaiser wilhelm
der zweite bis heute ist die burg im
privatbesitz der hohenzollern in der
stammbaum halle ganz unter der decke
stehen die jüngsten familienmitglieder
darunter georg friedrich prinz von
preußen
hier das hier sie prinz georg friedrich
von preußen vor fünf jahren hat er die
fürstentochter sophie von isenburg
birstein geheiratet
erst heute das familienoberhaupt
für kinder gibt es spezielle führungen
mit verkleidung und rittertum zum
anfassen wenn du magst darfst du das
kennenlernen in die hand nehmen du bist
doch stark das wiegt 6 kilo in der
schatzkammer gibt's kostbares aus dem
familienbesitz
berühmt ist die verbeulte
schnupftabakdose von friedrich dem
großen
in ihr blieb eine gewehrkugel stecken
und rettete dem könig das leben hier die
mit brillanten und diamanten besetzte
krone des letzten deutschen kaisers die
burg hohenzollern ist auch ein beliebter
ort für verlobungen und hochzeiten wie
viel dieses chinesische paar